roberto nero bienvenue à paris bienvenue en
double jeu
vous êtes à paris pour l'ouverture du
premier film produit par votre
société de production alors que vous êtes le premier
acteur au monde pourquoi s'impliquer si
étroitement dans la production
euh eh bien je voulais en
avoir plus  contrôler les choses en
étant simplement un acteur à louer dire que
je voulais être impliqué dans la création de
choses créer des idées
proposer des idées puis
amener les gens
à les exécuter réalisateurs scénaristes et ainsi
de suite et j'ai pensé essayer ça une fois dans ma
vie
et voyez comment ça se passe alors c'est le moment
avant de parler de la maîtresse hollywoodienne,
j'aimerais savoir si tribeca a
produit autre chose puisqu'il a
produit un
film appelé Thunderheart
qui a été réalisé par michael apted qui a
ouvert ses portes en Amérique quelques semaines  il y a
et il n'a pas ouvert ici
donc mais euh
maîtresse n'a pas ouvert en Amérique ça va
ouvrir ici en premier
donc et nous avons euh
et qu'en est-il de votre premier film en tant que
réalisateur du conte du bronx c'est
une histoire de passage à l'âge adulte un gamin de 9 à 17 ans
dans le bronx ouais que diriez-vous
aux gens pour qu'ils aient envie d'
aller voir le film si vous étiez un
annonceur
c'est un film personnel et pourtant c'est drôle
il a un  beaucoup d'humour dedans euh
et ça montre un certain style
un certain euh certain
élément de
la vie c'est euh
et ce que c'est que d'avoir un film
essayer et faire financer un film si vous êtes dans
la position des gars dans le
personnage de marvin dans le film qui
est ce que barry a traversé pendant longtemps en
essayant de le faire euh
le faire j'ai été dans cette situation en
tant que jeune acteur j'ai des amis qui sont
dans cette situation
c'est très très difficile à obtenir
financement indépendant pour un film euh
et moi je dirais que c'est marrant tu
devrais le voir mm-hmm
parfois j'appellerais un acteur
euh pour trancher euh
euh tu sais avec des agents parfois
ils ne le font pas si ce n'est pas un
film assez important pour eux ils
ne vous rappellent pas ou ils n'appellent pas
le réalisateur de retour, ils ne rappellent pas le
producteur, donc je suis un acteur et si
j'appelle quelqu'un,
je pourrais le connaître, alors je coupe
toutes les conneries, je les appelle juste et
dis que tu sais que tu veux le faire ou
non tu le lirais sinon tu sais au
moins on a une réponse rapide et
et euh
et ça dans ce sens c'était une aide
comment as-tu réagi quand il t'a dit que
tu auras une maîtresse noire dans le
film c'était un total  coïncidence
vous passez votre journée aujourd'hui avec la
presse euh auriez-vous été
si actif si vous n'aviez pas été le
producteur
je voulais aider le film
je veux aider le film à avoir une
présentation décente parce que ce genre de
film juste par la nature  de cela devrait être
présenté de cette façon cela ne devrait pas être
fait
avec un grand studio parce qu'ils ne le feraient pas
ils ne sauraient pas comment ils ne
savent pas quoi en faire c'est pourquoi ils
ne l'étaient pas  intéressé par la première place
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire à paris
qu'est-ce que je fais à paris
j'aime aller à goo  d restaurants ouais
bon repas ça et ça t'as passé la
nuit à la bandoche déjà j'y suis allé
ouais j'y étais l'autre soir
ouais t'as apprécié ouais genre je vais
te torturer un peu un peu je vais
te poser des questions c'est des interviews  nous sommes
habitués à pratiquer dans ce spectacle et le
premier est la première
interview de
quelque chose vous souvenez-vous du premier film que vous avez vu je
pense que l'un des premiers films que j'ai jamais vu
était la belle et la bête
et
certains des abbott costello et les
trois  les comparses
et le premier style dont tu as adoré
bien celui que j'aimais
beaucoup c'était elizabeth taylor quand j'étais euh
quand j'étais enfant gina lola bridgette
ouais
sophia loren ouais
ton premier travail
bien quand j'étais enfant je le faisais
se démarquer un peu dans la rue et vendre des
choses de ma maison dont je voulais
me débarrasser comme vous le savez
comme une vente de garage ouais vous souvenez-vous de
votre premier million de dollars
il y a 15 ans ouais
pour le film film humide de euh
le cerf  chasseur ouais
et si tu devais mourir maintenant quelle serait
ta dernière volonté
si je devais mourir maintenant je veux juste
m'assurer que tout le monde que je connais et que
j'aime et que je suis autour ils sont tous
pris en charge comme je le ferais  comme eux,
j'ai fait faire ma volonté correctement
parce que quand tu meurs c'est la dernière
déclaration que tu fais aux gens et c'est
très important et ça dure pour le reste
de leur vie donc
je voudrais que ce soit
en ordre ouais d'
accord merci nous  ira à un autre
type d'interview maintenant c'est l'
interview wu brian de palma
nous avons fait trois ou quatre films ensemble
rien d'autre une seconde un
premier était euh euh
la noce
salutations salut maman
et je pense euh beaucoup d'intouchables
marcel carney
bien je  était une
figure d'art supplémentaire qui était un film appelé twash
manhattan il y a
25 30 25 il y a 26 ans
martin scorsese
bon ami bien euh
je suis content nous avons notre relation
sergio leone
euh peut reposer en paix
francois
bon cinéaste
elia cazon
grand cinéaste
ce n'est que du bien
euh
contr
cinéaste oversial barry primus
un cinéaste passionné
jardi pardew
un grand acteur français ouais très bon
acteur français
tu penses qu'un ami ouais et as-tu déjà
entendu parler d'un gars qui s'appelle lauren buffy non
tu n'as jamais entendu parler de lauren buffy non
jamais de ta vie
lauren buffy ouais toi  Je n'ai jamais entendu
parler de lui,
il est très célèbre et devrais-je savoir qui
il fait
ce qu'il fait, il est très célèbre en
France, vous n'en avez jamais entendu parler.
d'accord que préférez-vous
en tant qu'acteur
vous avez la chance
de jouer différents rôles et d'être
exposé à différents modes de vie et modes
de vie
modes de comportement peu importe ce que d'
ordinaire je n'aurais pas spécialement
dans ma position je reçois
euh
je rencontre  des gens de tous les horizons
et ils euh
et parce que vous savez qu'ils sont ils
aiment l'idée que vous êtes curieux à
leur sujet et donc ils veulent vous parler d'
eux et de ce qu'ils font
donc  que vous pouvez euh ça aide en quelque sorte à les
immortaliser en
sachant qu'ils contribuent
à euh
euh quelque chose que vous faites dire à propos d'
une personne comme eux
et qu'est-ce que vous avez mangé en étant un acteur
interviewé
bien les interviews sont  d'accord parfois je
pense que c'est juste euh
je pense que si vous êtes un acteur à succès et que
vous ne pouvez pas le laisser contrôler votre vie
en termes de ce que les gens pensent ou font ou
si c'est négatif ou même positif
quel était votre meilleur casting
bien j'ai  les gens me demandent ça parfois
et c'est difficile c'est difficile à dire parce que
chaque personnage que je fais ou chaque film dans lequel
je suis impliqué j'ai l'impression que c'est
comme un enfant ou une progéniture et tu te
sens
très euh tu te sens comme si tu étais  être
déloyal envers l'autre si vous dites
trop en faveur de l'un, je veux dire que c'est mon
sentiment à propos de la
vérité, vous savez et chaque partie est différente,
chaque personnage a un problème différent,
un ensemble différent
de problèmes et donc on peut être
différent phys peut être  plus difficile
physiquement  mais pas aussi difficile mentalement
vous savez et vice versa et donc je ne veux pas
dire que je me sens
très euh très
protecteur envers eux tous et c'est en dehors
de tout ce que j'ai fait ou
je pense
que c'est spécial je veux dire que je ne le fais pas  comme
par exemple si quelqu'un
me dit comme euh, dis euh
la chose que tu as dit dans les chauffeurs de taxi et
ils diront ça ou feront ça et ils
ne veulent pas dire qu'ils le font juste euh euh
ils le font comme euh
c'est juste que ça
déprécie en quelque sorte la chose et c'est euh et
minimise ça je m'en fiche que j'ai le
sens de l'humour à propos de moi et de
tout ça mais
que parfois tu connais des gens euh ils
ne réalisent pas
euh qu'ils  Je demande de faire quelque chose peut-être
qu'ils savent que c'est euh
et la pire
la pire chose dans laquelle j'ai été ouais
il y avait du caractère
eh bien je ne dirais pas ça parce que
tout ce que j'ai fait, je veux me tenir derrière donc
je ne serais pas
le plus grand  moment de votre carrière
était quand j'ai eu le rôle et
après avoir fait des salutations et
j'allais faire un film appelé  haute maman avec
le palmer et juste le
il y avait une certaine quantité d'euh
euh d'
attention euh qui a
été générée par le film c'était comme
un film souterrain souterrain à ce
moment-là souterrain souterrain quel
que soit le film indépendant donc
euh et c'était la première fois parce que
jusqu'à ce moment-là, j'étais plus ou moins
vraiment en
difficulté et j'ai lutté
pendant de nombreuses années après cela, mais à cet
âge, cette époque de ma vie était une étape qui
était ouais c'était euh alors c'était comme si c'était bon de
ressentir le pire moment  de
votre carrière,
je pense que lorsque j'ai perdu quelques rôles
que je voulais, j'ai ressenti alors que se passe-t
-il lorsque vous n'obtenez pas quelque chose pour
lequel vous savez que vous avez absolument raison,
je ne me suis jamais senti mal si un autre acteur
l'obtiendrait.  la pensée était aussi bonne
que ferait un aussi bon travail ou mieux
je dirais que c'est comme ça je t'avais fait
savoir plus tu sais que c'est comme ça que ça
devrait être parfois euh
ou
même pas parfois tu sentais juste que c'était
ton coup  ou une chance à som  eth
et je l'ai perdu quelques fois,
ça
vous fait en quelque sorte commencer à penser à toutes
les choses négatives en vous et en
quelque sorte euh boules de neige
mais ça dure deux trois jours et c'est
fini
qu'est-ce que tu penses être le plus sexy à propos de
toi
je ne sais pas je ne suis pas sûr de ça
et il me reste à dire tu sais
qu'ils sont moins sexy je ne peux même pas répondre à
celui-là
ok maintenant on fait l'interview idiote c'est
à dire sera plus idiot  pouvez-vous l'
imaginer
préférez-vous staline ou hitler
exactement c'est très idiot c'est idiot je
ne peux pas je ne sais pas qui
ni l'un ni l'autre je suppose que la
bombe arrive dans cinq minutes que faites-vous dirigez-vous
vers le sous-sol ouais
imaginez que vous deviez vivre pendant trois ans
dans une navette spatiale préféreriez-vous
être avec ronald reagan
george bush
oh mon dieu ce chef
je pense que je préférerais être avec
gorbatchev
je ne sais pas pourquoi
maintenant le vierge w quel est votre idéal de
le bonheur sur terre
euh
je dirais l'harmonie l'harmonie dans le monde
où les gens
s'entendre et dire
quel est l'état de votre esprit en prison
euh déprimé
avez-vous une devise je m'en fiche
euh
eh bien je dirais
euh fais aux autres ce que tu voudrais que les
autres te fassent ouais
et maintenant la dernière interview le confucéen
interview
quelle est votre position sur l'avortement vous
savez si c'était un homme dans cette situation je
pense que cela n'aurait même jamais été une
question
qu'il aurait eu le droit de faire
ce qu'il veut mais puisque c'est une femme
ça semble un peu absurde ce qui est  votre
position sur l'
euthanasie
je pense qu'à un moment donné c'est probablement
bien parce que si tout le monde est d'
accord c'est peut-être la meilleure chose à faire la
peine de mort
je pense que certaines personnes méritent probablement
la peine de mort et ne devraient pas être
là et je sais que je pourrais parler  car
tu sais que je pourrais parler de préserver
la vie d'une personne qui l'est mais je
ne peux pas euh je ne pourrais jamais parler
au nom de la famille qui a perdu
l'enfant le mari la fille la
femme
qui a été tuée par l'autre perso  n
et si j'étais dans cette personne je voudrais
probablement je veux probablement au moins une condamnation à mort à
propos de la légalisation des drogues douces
euh peut-être que d'une certaine manière, cela devrait être
légalisé parce que cela le rend moins
rentable pour les mauvaises personnes ouais
et
là  y a-t-il des choses plus importantes dont
il faut s'inquiéter
crois-tu au bien
je ne crois pas en dieu je crois qu'il
y a quelque
chose là-bas en termes de
spiritualité commune je ne veux pas dire que c'est
dieu en soi
merci robert
[Musique  ]
bleu